The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons License.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
SAL BARRIGA: Hi, I'm Sal.
Today, we're going to
solve Problem #5 of
Exam 3 of Fall 2009.
Now before you start this
problem, there are a couple of
things that you need to know
in order for you to fully
understand the science
behind it.
And so what you need to know
is Fick's first law.
Not just knowledge of it,
but how it works.
Also, Fick's second law.
And not necessarily the
equation form, but the
solution to Fick's second law,
which is a function of
concentrations, and which
we will refer to
to solve the problem.
And also know popular
dislocations, how they help
your material and whatnot.
So the problem reads
as follows.
Specimens of steel are being
surface hardened by the
introduction of carbon.
The concentration of carbon at
the free surface of the steel
is kept constant at c sub s.
Chemical analysis of a number
of specimens indicate that
after a time--
t sub 1--
the carbon concentration has the
value of c star at a depth
from the surface-- x1--
shown below, which is
shown on your graph.
So this is given to you.
So this pretty much is your
concentration profile as a
function of position.
And it's telling you
what's happening.
So a good thing to do is draw
a picture of the science
that's happening here.
And they tell you, first of
all, I'm going to draw it
underneath here that you
have a rod of steel.
And so this is steel.
And I have a certain fixed
concentration here at the
surface of carbon.
So I have some type of a carbon
flux in my surface.
And this is a visual image
of how it looks.
And what the problem says is
that you have a certain
concentration on your surface,
which is given by c sub s.
And then it starts telling you
that chemical analysis was
able to go ahead and measure
this concentration at two
different values inside your
position at different times.
So if I continue reading the
problem, it says that chemical
analysis of a number of
specimens indicate that after
a time-- t1--
the carbon concentration
has a value of c star.
So this one right here--
this is x1--
so this has a value
of x1 at t1.
And it also tells you that after
a certain time-- t2,
which is equal to 2 times t1--
the carbon concentration has a
value of c star, so the same
value at a depth of x2.
So now, this thing says that at
a depth of x2, at a time of
t2, we measure the same
concentration, c sub star in
the specimen.
And it tells you that x2 equals
2x1, and it also tells
us that t2 equals 2t1.
Now they tell us that for a
reason, because it's probably
expected for us to use this to
solve the problem, so don't
forget that.
So the question is, under these
conditions, would you
describe the rate of
carburization as one, steady
state diffusion.
Two, transient state
diffusion.
Or three, not governed by any
diffusion, i.e., rate limited
by some other process.
Now you have to justify
your choice.
So this is pretty much a
problem of process of
elimination.
And for part a, which is--
I'll label this part a--
it wants us to do
three things.
So the first thing, it asks
us if it's steady state.
So the first thing to ask
yourself is, well, what's
steady state?
And the definition of steady
state is that whatever
phenomenon is happening doesn't
vary with time.
But the problem already tells
you that it varies with time.
It tells you that at a certain
time you measure this and at
another time you measure this,
and you have this flux coming
in, and this is what's
happening.
So from just reading the
problem, I can already say
that this process can't be
steady state, because your
concentration profile varies
as a function of time.
So for one, I would write, can't
be steady state due to
the concentration being
a function of time.
So one is out, so we
can scratch that.
It's not a steady state.
Now two.
This is where it gets a little
bit more complicated.
Two is a transient
state diffusion.
Well, how do we know whether
or not this is
governed with time?
Well, you would argue, because
this is not steady state, then
it has to be time dependent.
But, there are certain rules
that you need to know to be
able to make that
justification.
First of all, if it's time
dependent, then whatever your
concentration and whatever your
position in your time is,
has to fit into your solution
to Fick's law.
So if I look at my solution to
Fick's law right here, I know
that on the left side of
my equation, I have the
concentration at any
point in x--
that's what c stands for--
minus the concentration
at my surface,
which is given as cs--
sorry, this is supposed
to be sub s--
divided by the initial
concentration.
So c sub naught is if there was
already some carbon in my
steel, minus, again, the
surface concentration.
This equals to an
error function--
which is the solution to
Fick's second law--
and this error function has
the values of position,
diffusion coefficient,
and time.
So in order to verify if it's a
transient state, we're going
to go ahead and take that
equation and break it down.
So if I assume that there's no
carbon, I can go ahead and
write this down.
Assume c0 is 0, just to make
the equation easy.
I can, because there was no
information given about that.
I can go ahead and--
because we're trying
to figure out if
it's a transient state--
write this down.
So c minus c sub s over
negative c sub s.
This equals to my error
function, which is x divided
by 2 squared of Dt.
And I know that at x1
and time-- t1--
I have this value of my
concentration, c sub star.
So I'm going to go ahead
and plug that in
here into this equation.
So I know that my concentration
is c sub star.
So that's what we measured, c
sub star minus c sub s over
negative c sub s.
This equals to my error
function, x1 over 2 square
root of Dt1.
So this is for the first
time point, x1, t1.
Now I want to go ahead
and do the same thing
for the second point.
And if I do it for the second
point, I know that just by
looking at the equation, I have
the same concentration at
x2, and I have the same
surface concentration.
So what that tells me is that
this value is going to be the
same for x1, t1, and x2, t2.
So if I go ahead and plug
this into my equation.
I can go ahead and look at this
and say, this is for t
equals 1 for that, and
this is going to be--
or, t equals t sub 1, sorry--
and this is t sub 2.
I have c star minus cs
all over negative cs.
This equals to my error function
of x2 over 2 square
root of Dt2.
So I know that this value is
the same as this value.
So therefore, this should
be the same as this.
The argument in both your
error functions.
So we have to go ahead
and prove that.
Well, how are we going
to do that?
Do I know x2 as a
function of x1?
I do, because that's
given in the data.
And I know again, that x2 equals
2x1 and t2 equals 2t1.
So what I want to know, does x1
over 2 root Dt1, does this
equal to x2 over 2 root Dt2?
Well, I'm going to go ahead and
plug in my values that I
know, and this becomes 2x1
divided by 2 times the square
root of D--
and t2 happens to be 2t1.
So those two cancel each other
out, and I end up getting that
this is actually equal to x1
over square root of 2Dt1.
Now this and this are
not the same.
Because this has a square root
of 2, where the other
one is just a 2.
So because it did not satisfy
the solution to Fick's second
law, we can say that it's
not case two either.
This is not transient
state diffusion.
So therefore, by the process of
elimination, it has to be
governed by some other
phenomena.
And that is the answer
to this problem.
The fact that it's governed by
something that we don't have
enough information to answer.
We don't have enough data
points to answer.
So that's part a,
which is good.
Now part b asks, if the steel
specimens in part a were
replaced with steel specimens
of identical composition but
with a dislocation density 10
times greater than that of the
steel in part a, how
would the rate of
uptake of carbon change?
Explain.
Again, this requires you
to know properties of
dislocations, and what
dislocations do to your materials.
Your metals, for example.
What is a dislocation?
Well, a dislocation is--
if you have a bunch
of a plane of atoms--
what a line dislocation is, or
an edge dislocation is, this
line defect such that
it just terminates.
So you have a plane of atoms
that just comes to a point and
then it stops.
And what do you create here?
Well it creates void, and void
facilitates diffusion.
It increases--
in our case, we're talking
about carbon
diffusion into steel--
so I would argue that the more
dislocations that you have,
the greater the diffusion
should be.
Because you have more
void-- more spaces--
for your carbon atom to
jump into and from.
So for part b, just by arguing
the fact that dislocations
represent defects in
your crystal--
specifically a defect that
can create void--
then with that argument, the
fact that more void means
higher diffusion, I would
conclude that--
for this part--
that my rate of diffusion of
carbon should increase when
using steel of a greater
dislocation density.
So the rate of carbon uptake
or diffusion of carbon into
your steel increases
as you increase
your dislocation density.
And with that, you're to be able
to solve a lot of these
problems. And these are
common in 3.091.
And again, knowledge of Fick's
first and second law, how to
use the solutions to Fick's
first, second law, and knowing
what a dislocation is, that will
help you a lot in solving
these problems.